this is one of the areas that I really
wanted to talk to you about because it
always raises its head with the police
it's stop and search there lot of people
say that it's it's a racist policy I
stopped and searched for our globe
audience is where they police stopped
young men mainly young black men in
searching for knives and all the rest of
it do you agree with it do you disagree
with it where do you stand on it I mean
my view on it is quite an interesting
area here because it's like we've moved
to full circle with yourself example
you'd get you get two voices on this you
get people say I'll stop and search is
bad and it's a it's oppressive it goes
in from one community but then when
there is a knife crime the police are
blamed because they're not there in it I
said we're the police you know and
usually get that from the victims side
and work well so suddenly we've got a
shift in this and it's it's more towards
saying that okay we need we need more
police so my view on it is I think knife
crime doesn't need quite specific
policing why just think it does it
shouldn't he doesn't need saturating
policing what you start with in the 70s
80s was a crime would be committed did
every black man in the village in a
radius of about 5 miles will stop just
because you know you you just I mean
that was that just caused mass prom I
think the police have got enough
intelligence on this one to be able to
do some targeted things where they know
where those those criminals are and
where they're hanging out and I think
they should use stop and search in that
that more intelligent way so I do think
you need it we just need to be done
better you know coming back to the
fatherlessness thing one of the things I
found very worrying in the piece that
you had in The Times yeah you talking
about the fact that you're trying to get
this message out there that
fatherlessness is the problem and the
pushback is that a lot of the white
politicians and other people you talk to
they don't want to raise this issue they
don't want to deal with it because of
fear of being called racist yeah right
so how and and I can't wrap my head
around that that doesn't make sense to
me yeah I mean I think that it was even
worse when I used to come out with stuff
around exclusion from schools and boys
and say the black boys and say that look
this this issue isn't necessarily about
Ray
but it's actually about some other
things going on in the home in the peer
group and we've got to tackle this you
know and I think equally with with with
the knife crime issue I though I think I
must admit there is less of a there's
less of a sense now that people are I
think the more willingness I think to go
to that area now because of the numbers
are so clear that it is
disproportionately black boys are
involved in this however I do think that
when we come to the solutions that
aiming this I mean and my friend David
Lammy is a classic example I mean David
in 2012 he was before me he said you can
just go online just tapping David Lammy
knife crime and up will come all these
articles about him saying black homes
need black fathers I mean states that
you know and and yet now it's sort of
not politically kind of so correct to do
that
I hear he's roaring back a bit on it you
know he's not coming up and so you get
that sort of sense that there's a
sensitivity around this and nobody wants
to come out and state that as an issue
why and I think that I think it's also
who says it I think it's because there
is a focus on the victim what one it is
is they're saying that the the the thing
that always helps us out is the white
male if we if we can find anything to
hook it on him it's a get out of jail
card for us yeah so therefore you're
screwed in this particular is that see
though it what what way wait a minute
you know we can't we cannot we cannot
blame the victim here it's got to be
something to do with with with him or at
least he's a is is measures so it's to
do with Tory austerity is to do with the
fact isn't a youth club just to do with
the police you know and then the way
they see themselves it's to do with with
with white teachers excluding them from
schools anything and everything but not
the hope I think that's the progress so
that's really worried so but once you
start going back into the home you don't
you talk about agency then you talking
about responsibility of those
those communities and that's that's the
difference you see there nobody wants to
take that especially if you're a
politician who's who's been kind of
almost put up on on the basis that I am
here to protect you from that horrible
world the walls out there that are
coming to get you
so therefore my narrative has always got
to come back to the fact that you're
oppressed not for the fact that the
oppression might be something to do with
what's going on in your home
yeah and or another type of oppression
that you might be perpetuating yourself
no you can't go there and that's where
we that's that's where we become stuck
but what I think this this issue has
come up is that it as I said I think
that particularly black boys they're a
problem for that kind of rhetoric they
confound that because they as those boys
say look the biggest issue for me was
the fact that my old man left or he
wasn't there or downstairs I was busy
kind of refitting an air gun so that it
could be used as a God while my daughter
was upstairs doing well my sister was
upstairs doing her work and my dad or
the dads of the three of us the three
different dads just were not here that's
the reality that that I face you know
and so for me that's that's that's where
it it lies and so it's difficult for
communities to come back and say well
we've got to try and sort this out
ourselves you see what I don't
understand there's a guy in America
Larry old I don't know if you live with
him right and Larry he has some
interesting points along the same lines
that you make but he's a guy he just
talks right he's a radio host he's very
articulate very good but he talks right
but you've proven it through the work
that you do and still people are afraid
to say there should be hundreds of
generating geniuses around the country I
think that it yeah there should be and I
think that people are waking up to it
but I think that it's it's a harder one
I mean what what's also happened is that
the pot and here's another thing about
generating genius it makes it a little
bit different and people kind of don't
get it a bit
that what it's trying to do is saturate
the mindset of that community with young
people that are doing very well it's a
kind of it's a almost like a kind of
counterintuitive thing because what you
usually do in policies is you go you
said to say we're gonna stack all our
resources on on the very few kids that
are causing all this disruption now
admittedly I mean when they kill
somebody that's a massive disruption so
you've got to do something but what what
we're saying is that actually what you
need to do is you need to you need to
change a narrative around that group
that's not we like what we did with the
teenage girls and so therefore you you
actually may be needing to sort of go
off the as I say children are who are
and making sure that there is there is a
story for them what's quite interesting
is that the kids are my program come
from the same schools that the kids who
commit knife crime come from they come
from the same schools so it's not like
they're going off to eat no Harris
although the same estates the same
schools yet they're ending up at the top
universities so that that is powerful
you should I mean because you're saying
well although they could save money the
same is the same lack of youth clubs or
ever austerity they that same and to a
certain extent same lack of fathers and
that's quite interesting as well you
know in their in their homes and yet one
group is doing well another is and the
other one that confirms it all is girls
at the moment the group that is doing
best in London are girls from West
African background and they're doing
really well in school so what you've got
in some homes you've got the girl
upstairs busy doing our work going off
to top university and a boy downstairs
getting ready for prison and that is
happening in a lot of black homes too
pathways for the same kid in the same
household and so that's that's what you
what you're saying is absolutely right
in fact what you need then is is is is
something that's going to tackle the
real core the problem yeah not pushing
foot around it which is really what's
been
I mean in the past and it's because
we're not allowing ourselves and this is
probably I've never had this is the most
honest and open conversation I've ever
had with any media on this issue and
I've never heard people talk about it
openly because there's always this Oh
what should I show the right thing you
know all that and so we never get to it
[Music]